when you were growing up did you listen
to Eminem at all
well I ain't started listening to him
until like a year ago you know that like
what's that one song like that you only
get your chance to blow I never actually
listened to what he was talking about on
that yeah I finally listened to him Lose
Yourself yeah Lose Yourself so when I
finally this is doing I was hearing what
he was saying I'm like all right like
this hard for real for real it's so wild
that like this whole like new generation
of Detroit artists like just like Eminem
wasn't a big influence he's a daddy in
Eight Mile two he's in the movie yeah
I'll be right behind him on the last
battle going against so he's he's at the
shelter in the battle your dad's in the
video he ain't rapping no but he's in
the background can you point him out
when you watch the movie yeah yeah black
mink on you just gotta look right behind
him that's crazy
so did you watch Eight Mile obviously as
a kid you had to watch it yeah the whole
series your [ __ ] dad's in it man I
don't even know that until I got older
for real for real like he got a check
for that [ __ ] everything he got a check
yeah for playing in the movie that's
amazing
being I mean yeah extras get paid for
sure damn that's [ __ ] dope I'll tell
you this much I went to his uh spaghetti
restaurant yeah I ain't been there yet
it's terrible
it's God awful so where some of the
worst Food I've ever eaten I've never
been there yet me and uh the shitty boys
went uh shout out to Baby Tron from
Detroit
we went there and uh we tried this
spaghetti and it was
not good
somebody just asked me today
it feels like the kind of place only
like Taurus to like I wouldn't even let
everybody make my spaghetti for real for
real like you got your own way I know
like you know your mama make the
spaghetti that's the spaghetti you eat
they ain't gonna make it how your mama
make it ain't that the truth